this is what life was like in Grenfell
tower a birthday party in the flat of a
Leah Moses she is the center of her
large family and this was the center of
so much family life
it was also next door to the flat where
the fire started and now there's nothing
she and her family are safe but a leah
is rebuilding her life starting with
donations from the community and the
council supplied hotel room when you
left you left simply with your dressing
gown is that right all I had on me with
my dressing gown the slippers and the
house keys and my phone that was it so
this is you this is you starting from
scratch I am starting from scratch all
over again yeah what have you made of
the the aid stations the volunteers the
donations people have just been so given
and that's another thing that's really
got me overwhelmed as well the amount of
generosity that's out there random
people giving me money that I've never
seen in my life so you've been here
since the night yeah when it happened
yeah and you're going to be here for the
next week or so what happens after that
I have no idea
yeah it's just like I want somebody to
pinch me so that I can just wake up
because I feel like I'm in a dream it
comes like it's grand hot grand holiday
it doesn't feel real to you no it
doesn't
I need to sleep but I am now afraid
I'm afraid to go to sleep because if I
sleep when something happens I might not
know about it later we find a Lea on the
street nearby a protest march streams
past
[Music]
you saw them come past what we are so
emotions you sort I am the latest
because this is the kind of support that
we need people are walking around that
bloody zombies
everything's gone they've lost their
family lost friends lost your home lost
their identity my days this is just
ridiculous isn't it like hundreds of the
survivors it'll be months perhaps years
until life is back on track
Joe tidy Sky News